Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Clustered
at the Rawkode Academy. I am your host,
Rawkode.
Today, we have two great teams picking up
the clustered mantle and fighting each other to
win. This one's a bit weird because all
the teams know each other, and I think
it's gonna be a whole lot of fun.
Alright. Now before we get started, this is
a little bit of housekeeping. If you're not
already subscribed to the channel, I would encourage
you to do so now. Also, if you'd
be so kind, thumb up the video, like
it, comment, share, all those other things. It's
just gonna help YouTube share this content with
more people.
We also have membership options available at the
academy, so you can check them out and
join for as little as 99p
per month or cents,
and this just allows you to support it,
and I would appreciate that very much. And
if you want to continue
conversation or you're not watching live, we do
have a Discord server available at Rawkode.chat.
There's only 600 cloud native technologists in there
talking about all things cloud native, Kubernetes, EBPF,
and everything in between.
So come and say hello, and I look
forward to meeting you. I also want to
thank Teleport for sponsoring Clustered. This was the
easiest decision I've ever had to make. We've
been using Teleport since the very beginning. It
is a fantastic tool. You're going to see
us using it today to pair and share
terminal sessions on these rather broken clusters. So
check it out, get it running in your
cluster, and let us know how get on.
You just use rockhode.
Liveteleport.
It's a UTM link, but it keeps the
sponsor happy, so that keeps me happy.
Alright. So we had a little bit of
technical troubles, but we are back in action,
and I am gonna introduce our two teams
today. So let's pop over here. We have
a slightly different layout. We've got two teams
of two, which means we can have everybody
on the screen at the same time. It's
gonna be a whole lot of fun. Let's
start at the top left. Jack, do you
wanna say hello, introduce yourself, and then we'll
just move around the windows, please.
Sure. So I'm Jack from Control Plane. I'm
an infrastructure engineer.
Usually, I'm I'm doing more throwing stuff at
clusters.
But,
yeah, looking forward to to fixing some as
well.
Awesome. Thank you.
Hi, everyone. I'm James. I'm also from Control
Play.
I'm also used to
breaking things and pointing out broken things a
bit more, so looking forward to having to
fix some stuff up today.
Awesome. Thanks for sharing.
Hello. I'm Chris.
I'm
I guess, stumbled into some bits of DevOps.
I spend most of my time kinda helping
digital teams become kinda more efficient and
more empowered and enabled and stuff. I'm a
developer at heart. So
but, yeah, ended up kinda looking at DevOps
and other buzzword nonsense,
which made me stumble into Kubernetes.
And I'm currently a teacher at Learn k
eights. Awesome.
Thank you.
Hey. My name is Simonik Bao. And just
like Chris, I am also an instructor for
Kubernetes at Learn k eights, and I also
work as an MLOps engineer for Appia.
I usually break stuff and don't
bother fixing them. That's what I do. So
but today is gonna be a real test
for me to try and fix the broken
stuff.
Alright. Thank you all for introducing yourselves.
So we're gonna kick things off with our
first cluster. I have the learn Kate's cluster
in front of me. So that means team
control plane, you are up first.
This is teleport.
I am going to click here to open
a session on the control plane node. Please
do not use that button yourself. There is
the activity panel here and active sessions.
So make sure you join my session. I'm
gonna ask you to type echo hello or
echo your name, anything like that to let
me know that you're there.
And then I will start the timer and
we'll get the session underway.
Okay. Give you just a moment. So remember
active sessions and then join.
Got one of you. Is the newest one.
Alright. I guess that's it. We've got both
of you in the chat.
In the chat in the session.
Alright. I'm gonna start the timer. Feel free
to configure your cube config and best of
luck.
Okey dokey. Yeah. I guess you could you
could use
teleport and a session as the
as a chat.
I'm gonna get started by bringing some of
my own tools
just so that I can debug
nice and quick.
Doesn't like that. Okay. Never mind.
Right. Let's let's have a look what we're
working with.
What kind of tools were we done with
inject?
It
was going to be, like bringing my own
kubectl
just in case I can't trust it.
Oh, come on now. It's the first step.
You still Oh, no.
On. That's the first step. You've definitely watched
us before if you don't trust kubectl. I'm
just saying.
Yeah.
Okay. Let's get that going.
I mean, let's just have a look at
pods. Okey dokey. Oh, look at that. Maybe
you shouldn't have trusted it. Oh. Oh, yeah.
Damn.
Fixed it. Has it already fixed
If
I Let's see what that error was. I
haven't used it. You can't do it as
root. You'd have to add a user. Okay.
I have a solution for this already.
Jack came prepared.
This stream is not going to last too
long now. Okay. Let's grab this instead.
Copy.
Okay.
Cool. I have next portable.
Just make sure it works.
And then let me just grab my tools.
So I'm using next to grab a bunch
of tools. I could just write a script
with wget or whatever.
Oh, you're using next flakes as well, not
this next shell? Yes. Nice.
So
I'll I'll go over the tools that are
in there in a bit. But hopefully, once
this downloads a bunch of stuff,
we'll be able to see it a bit
clearer.
But in theory, if I didn't well,
in this I've got kubectl.
I've got, like, BusyBox,
you know, Rarkess.
I've got BAT so that I can get
some nice colors and
a couple other bits and bobs. I do
appreciate some colors. You
come prepared. Yeah. You Exactly. If you're typically
debugging
your own cluster, you probably don't need treat
it as such an adversary.
But yeah,
have seen some pretty nasty stuff during clustered,
so I thought bring your own tools might
help. I like it.
And yeah, I mean, hopefully that will fix
this problem. We can also look into kind
of what happened to
there.
I think messing with kubectl might be a
bit of a theme here.
But we'll see.
I could have also slimmed this down a
bit. I did pull in stuff like Docker
as well, which is a bit
bit too extra.
I think you did the right thing. You'll
need that. You'll need that later on.
So if I do which kubectl,
it's now in the next store.
That doesn't actually exist on the host. It's
because I'm using next portable.
It's in a different location.
But we can skip over that. So if
I do that
flake
next, we can see the tools.
I'm pulling in kubectl,
dig Nice. Proc s, nodectl,
yeah, bunch of other stuff. And I thought
busy box because
why even trust p s when you can
just bring your own?
So if we look at user bin
kubectl,
I guess yeah. So it's not executable.
I guess we could make it executable.
The other thing we can do is
We have a control plane control plane employee
going rogue
in this location.
We see Lewis popping his head up. Lewis,
what are you doing, man?
So we can see that they're they're roughly
the same size. There might have been some
meddling going on.
But they
are going to be built slightly differently anyway.
Are you going to try chip modding your
left Yeah.
Let's try it.
If it
yeah. Let's just see what it does.
I mean, hopefully, it doesn't, like, exit me
out of this session or something.
Okay. It looks it looks alright.
Okay. No API server. I like that.
Let me just use my one, just in
case.
That's
fine.
Right. What should we do now? Should we
should we check Kubla quickly?
Oh.
In a true.
K. Let's let's pop out of this.
K. Kubler. What's it doing?
Anything
popping out here
for you, James? So
we've got some some pods that are broken.
We're dialing 6443, but I'm not sure that's
particularly
that's maybe expected since API server isn't up.
Yes.
Okay.
We could
look at
PTC cube manifests.
Let's see if we can spot anything amiss
in the API server, YAML, maybe.
Yeah. That sounds like a a good good
thing
to try out. Let me just
grab my VIM again.
David, we're supposed to say hot or cold
if they're getting closer or or we're not?
No. If if they wanna hand, they can
give you a note. Alright. Just feel free
to taunt and laugh if you wish. Alright.
Draw stuff to loose if you want. That's
exactly where I'd That's exactly where I'd
I'll maybe save the taunts in the last
for the last five minutes if we get
anywhere near that.
Sounds good. Sounds good.
Perhaps, Jack, we could have a little look
at the time stamps on the files in
that folder to see if I am. Oh,
man. A lot of people Willy keeps Willy's
saying hot.
Let's have a look.
Okay.
Sixteen. So, yeah, manifest has changed.
Let's see if it manifests.
We're looking at the cube controller,
cube scheduler.
And as you do. As
well. I'm not looking forward to that. Yeah.
I love it when people have time stamps
from, like, thirty minutes before the show.
Yeah. Oh, shit.
Okay.
I mean There's some stuff modified a few
minutes before the show as well. Full closure.
Sure. Yeah. Start with XD.
Yeah. Can do.
The other thing I was thinking is I
have a I have a little
file
here that I can just
pop in here.
Okay.
Now you came prepared.
So let's see what the the diff is
for the Kubernetes
backups.
Kubernetes
manifests,
and then ETC.
That's Kubernetes Let's
pop this into
that
so we can have a look.
So let's see. Is there anything
odd that just looks
pretty normal stuff?
Let's have a scroll through.
That that read only, I think, looks pretty
sus.
Yeah. The read only is interesting for sure.
So which files that
that's the etcd manifest.
Okay.
Very nice.
Because yeah, I noticed in a lot of
these in a lot of these clustered
exercises, it's just a case of
what has changed and what has not. Okay.
Control has
been changed.
Are you seeing and learn, Kate, seeing this
being deconstructed right in front of you? Good.
It's learning experience for everyone. That's what we
want. Learn Yeah. People to learn about Kubernetes.
Now the breaks I'm
not familiar with this format.
So disable
replica sets.
Yeah. So the controllers,
can do dash replica set, dash replica,
replication controller. And it will disable that individual
controller and the controller manager.
Yeah. That's very cool. I guess I guess
if you know that you don't need something,
you can just remove it Yeah. To reduce
your attack surface.
Anything else of interest?
I could see that the replica set controller
might be quite useful, though.
Yeah. It probably is useful. We might want
that, I guess.
Right.
So let's
have a go. So I think the main
things there was the read only and the
rep cassettes.
Fact,
one of the files was touched, but I
didn't
notice any difference.
I wasn't paying a massive amount of attention.
It's
quite hard to notice these differences. Manifests.
SPEAKER
So I think there was one in etcd,
wasn't there? There was a read only. Two:
Yeah. That was the read only you spotted.
Okay.
Also, did it open on read only?
That's the other thing. Does does Vim open
where where the change happened?
It was controller.
Yeah. So so Vim has opened at where
the issue is.
It's always funny. Nice and helpful.
Yeah. I I was looking into that earlier,
and the file of interest is
is it Vim info? It's Vim info.
Yeah. VimInfo. So if we go in
VimInfo,
we can find some other interesting things that
I have edited.
We got it. We got it, Jack.
Keys to the castle. There we go. Yeah.
Gonna a very me, trying to think about
The big question is whether Jack and James
have cleared their Vim info before shutting down
their cluster.
I I don't think I'd be showing it
off.
We'd like
Okay.
So I'm
not sure why this file has been opened
either. I guess we'll find out. A lot
of laughter in the comments and people enjoying
the forensic approach for this.
Very good. Very good job. Right.
I think we there's also a cube fit.
It looked like it had been might have
been edited that we didn't spot earlier. So
I would to
you to touch that. Yeah. It turns out
we broke cube fit without trying to break
it.
Caused some issues.
So
Great tip from Russell there. Start editing all
files was said.
Mhmm.
Does the kubla just restart itself?
The Kubla won't restart itself. No. But it'll
restart any static manifests or modified when it
notices the change.
Got
it. Okay. Or you can force it with
the restart.
So,
I mean, it might be a minute or
two for the changes.
I guess the other thing we could look
into is that
other file that changed. So
prep.
There's a vet.
Yeah.
Or should we look at the VIP
first, actually?
Kubernetes
manifests.
Kubit.
So okay. And that one started at the
top,
which is interesting,
I guess.
Backups,
Kubernetes,
manifests,
kube, vip,
and then you see
kube manifests,
kube, vip.
And then I'll just pipe that into BAM
for some Oh, I don't have that. You're
not in the shell anymore. Escaped the shell.
What have we got here?
It's just custom made So, like, sensible differences,
yeah. I mean, in in theory, it could
have been changed, but we'll find out, I
guess.
Also, if KuBip
was screwed up, I guess we wouldn't be
in Teleport right now.
So
the other thing was
this file.
So this
is a file that I'm
not familiar with.
And, also, I do not have backup of,
so I can't just cheat.
I
don't know if you're familiar with this one
either, James.
But, yeah. Would
never touched this folder.
Okay. That looks very fun.
I'm not sure we even need this file.
So
I'm going to
can you comment? Maybe you can comment in
these files.
I, from
the name, would hazard a guess that the
if up dot d would run on interface
being brought up.
So potentially,
we might need to undo that in IP
tables.
Yes.
I'm also not very familiar with IP tables,
so I'm not looking forward to this.
Right. Okay.
So
so
My
yeah. At
some stuff. Don't know whether the state would
have been saved in the
save state file,
whether we can restore from that or whether
we'll just have to target it manually.
So you can run I b tables dash
capital l to list all the different rules.
And what dash t not properly to target
the NAT table
since that's where it's at it?
Would that just be the tile?
Let me just grab something with a t
a t.
James is right with the dash t net.
He don't need to do the the graph.
Oh. The dash is capital l, base dash
t net.
Can I do them in any order? Yeah.
Yes.
And you might want dash n as well,
which will give us the rule number.
Sounds very
low. Thanks, Anne. Oh, maybe not actually. Moment
ends. Maybe you don't need the l of
the dash t.
No. You don't. Okay.
This seems a bit noisy. But
Yes.
Let me just do a clear
right. While we're
with him.
So I think about middle of the screen,
there's the offending rule in the output chain.
Mhmm. Oh, yeah. My my highlight isn't showing.
Yeah. Below the second Cilium comment.
Yeah.
So I guess we have two options. We
can either delete that rule
or change the whole cluster so that it's
not on that port anymore. Just a
quick bit of Google food to try and
remind myself exactly
the IP tables incantation.
Sounds good. I'm gonna The comments are spot
on if you need them.
Yep. I think dash dash line numbers is
the The tack is flag I was looking
for earlier. All of it.
There we go. Yes. That's the
Okay. Roger.
We have a number,
okay.
I'm not familiar with how I would target
that. I guess it's on output. Right? Dash
I think you need the t not, and
then it's is it dash capital d for
drop, and then the line number?
If my very rusty memory serves me correctly.
So t now. Or you could always take
the sledgehammer approach, which is the
the Rawkode approved way.
Wash all the rules. Can I just wipe
everything and then wait for it to be
rebuilt? You
can. I will also point out this is
a Cilium cluster with no cube proxy using
e b p f and x t p
for traffic routing. So, I have tables.
Well,
I seem there's a couple of Cilium things
in here. So
is that just for compatibility?
So Yeah. Just not work together or I'm
pretty confident you can make it and this
this machine will be fine.
Valid suggesting this anyway. Flush it. Yes. Yes.
Could do. Okay.
That would be dash capital f to flush
everything.
Okay.
So should we just wing it? If you
I have the I think I have the
command if you just wanted to delete the
single one. Yeah. Let's let's go with the
slightly safer option. I don't want the cluster
to implode.
Then Dash capital d. Definitely run out of
time.
Do I need the
the NAT thing?
Yes.
Was it t NAT or n NAT? Yeah.
T NAT.
Cap d,
output in caps,
and then the rule number, which was
two, was it? Yeah. Yes.
Okay.
Moment of truth.
Is it gone?
It is gone. Nice.
Okay. Kubectl
get pods.
Tada.
We are in more business than we were
earlier.
Guess, well, while we're here
SPEAKER This is a nice tool for anyone
doing their CCAD. You can look at all
the short names
if you want to do the the
shorthand for, like, pods and deployments and whatnot.
Cool. So
we've got the pods
there.
I guess I should look in teleport to
see
if the service is running.
In fact, let's just get
can I just curl this?
You
are halfway through. Twenty minutes left.
Okey dokey.
Okay. So
it seems to be running fine.
Oh, another thing that's really good is
remember the
completion
stuff.
Cool.
Do we want to preemptively check for any
admission
controllers potentially?
Or should we just try and
and go ahead and edit the
I think, yeah, going going ahead with an
edit
sounds fine. I can't I can't see it
causing any
issues that are non recoverable.
Kubectl
edit, deploy,
and then cluster.
Cluster.
Did
I misspell it? There you go.
And then v one,
v two, please.
Let me just have a scroll through this,
see if there's anything that
What? You don't trust them?
I can't remember if it was health or
health z. That's something to Yeah. I can
never remember if it's health or health z.
It's cluster first, which was the nasty one
from last time,
rather than it was on, what was it,
default?
I would never have caught that. Yeah. Matt
tried to stick that one past me, but
I wasn't letting him have that.
Okay.
Let's get pods.
Alright. You want me to test it? Looks
like it restarting. I think so. Yeah. If
you could.
That would be handy.
Moment of truth.
Salmon looks worried.
My my worry was over two minutes and
as soon as you downloaded the tools, was
like, this is done. This is done.
You got advanced. Well Good job. Done. Good
job, John. Done.
So I can change this. Good job.
That's a master master class in forensic debugging.
That was very good.
Thanks. Yeah. I I would have been completely
stumped there on on IP tables. I avoid
that like the plague.
No. No. You did well. I like the
approach. You know, you took it slow. You
just identified
what you wanted to you wanted to check
for history. You wanted to check for them
info. You had you came prepared with backups.
Like, you know, that's
a great way to do it. Nicely done.
Very well done.
Alright. Certainly scratching
the back of my memory on some of
those commands.
Okay. So this is our first stream of
ultra ultra low latency on YouTube and the
chat I want this to run a test
to see how low that latency is.
So put your fingers on the one key
and then I'm gonna say go and you're
all gonna press 1. And I'm gonna get
that cluster ready just now while I do
that.
All right, so control plan.
Cool.
All right, go.
That's some more comments.
I'm not seeing anyone yet, so it's still
not all lit and see enough.
I I can hear you on the stream.
They've got on the TV.
It's it's not that far. Yeah. The late
there's not much latency to be honest.
Yeah. It's not too bad. Alright. Thank you
all.
Alright. Let's jump back over to our screen
share.
So I have the control plane cluster here
now. So if the learn Kate's team,
Norman and Chris, if you can jump in
and join this session, remember to use active
sessions and join.
Type echo hello, echo your name, anything you
wish. Let's make sure they're all on the
same page and then we'll get this thing
started.
Thank you to everyone who typed a I
think it is a lot better, definitely.
Of course, Lewis comes in twelve minutes later.
Nice one, mate.
Am I in the right one? I'm not
sure if I
see nope.
Just me and Chris.
Sessions.
I'm in active sessions and the only active
session I see is learn cades.
You're
in the wrong cluster. Join the control plane
cluster. Teleport control plane dot cluster dot Yeah.
Oh,
right. There you go. We're good.
Give a second.
I'm gonna start your timer now, Simon, for
being so unprepared. That's what's gonna happen. It's
it's not gonna make any difference. I'll just
throw it away. I was just like, Jack,
you got this.
I gotta do authenticator now real quick.
We're now about to demo how to absolutely
not prepare for one of these
and and fail miserably.
No.
You're just gonna do great. Like, I host
the Kubernetes office hours and we share your
learn case debugging image
a lot for people. So we we got
a lot of confidence in you and we're
looking forward to you fixing this cluster.
Uh-huh. Because they prepared to be disappointed. I'll
I'll put that warning out when that
Yeah. For some reason, I can't log in
controlplanecluster.live.
Different login. It's your the other one. Did
you register for both?
No. I didn't register for both.
Anyway.
Chris is doing the taping. You can do
the navigating. I'm gonna start your timer now.
So
set up your cube config and let's check
for our control plane and best of luck.
Cool.
Where is it?
Yeah.
Just
no LS.
Cool. Okay.
So is that no LS or no
Well, that's weird because LS should be a
built in into the shell. So that's that's
a nice Yeah. But I've got no built
in
things.
You have echo?
I have echo. I have a a thing,
and I can see that I'm maybe in
bash.
No. Come on bash.
Docker.
Interesting.
They know. You know, they're not gonna get
cube cut. You're not gonna leave me that,
are you?
So it looks like you're missing a lot
of things. So how how does the shell
find binaries?
By path.
Yes. There
we go. Ah, fine. Okay. Fine.
So, yeah, my path messed up. Thanks.
Thank Cool. Thank you. Yeah. Interesting. Okay. So
You could echo path and fix it. Yeah.
What would it normally be? Maybe there's something
like
just in case there's anything in there.
You trust what's in there?
No. I think we're not going.
Oh, have you done something? Yeah. I trust.
There you go. Trust pretty much anything in
the path.
There's only one thing.
No. The absence of a path. I can
trust that. Cool. You're talking about. Yeah. There
you go.
Guess the other thing you could think about
is,
like, how would we have removed the path?
Oh, okay. Fine.
Of course, fine.
Ben.
It's bash, isn't it?
Try.
It's the easiest way to restart the session,
where I can source this.
Yeah. You can source It will work, because
we we put the original path at the
top of the file as well. Oh, okay.
Cool. You should add it back in.
Great. Fine. Cool. Thank you. Okay. Fine. First
stumbling block. Okay. So I can now do
Have I still got my Kube config?
Yep. Fine. So more, etcetera.
So
that looks
reasonably unsuspect.
There's there's fixing piece, Lewis. Come on.
So
pod's currently in a state where it's got
many
Many. Readiness.
Well, it got elite readiness,
I guess. Yes. And a terminating state.
So this is the binary I wouldn't trust.
Gonna give you a minute, Jack. CTL.
I'd say this is the binary I wouldn't
trust. Keep CTL binary.
Interesting.
Okay.
So
we had all sorts of aspirations of a
bad keeping a bad KubeCole
and never got around to doing it. So
kudos for actually doing the thing that we
planned to do. To be fair, we did
want to do something like changing the code,
but it was way too difficult. So it
did sound very, very crude.
Yeah. I had to look at changing the
code. Was like, well, not for the not
for now. Later on. Should we just get
a new
should we just get should we just download
a new one and
QTTR.
Stick there.
Then
judging by what, like, just the clue that
we just got, I'm wondering whether that's
yes. Only smalls is probably a shell script
that's aliasing to it being somewhere else, which
is what I was gonna do for us,
and then we didn't even get to do
that.
There you go. There you go.
I'm not so I can
Just get rid of that.
Right.
Now what does it look?
So that's a real kubectl
this time.
Interesting.
Cool.
Okay.
And it's got zero red.
Yeah. Should we just delete this deployment and
create a run first?
We could just do, like, a run.
I don't know. It's a busy box.
Yeah.
Search
Oh, it's dash dash image.
Uh-oh. Yeah. This this isn't meant to happen.
This is
me not knowing how JS policy works very
well.
But
it it would be it would be blocking.
Yeah. I would have an admit there's there's
an admission control knocking about. It's called JS
Poly, so you do something. So
Files look
so if you've changed them, you've moved the
dates back.
So what was it? JS policy
is somewhere doing something.
There is no docker on these machines.
That's oh, yeah. Brain fart.
Right. Okay. So JS policy was the thing
that you tried to put in, but that's
gonna crash back a little bit. Yeah. Sometimes
it works. Sometimes it doesn't. We're
not sure why.
Haven't used it enough to to judge.
The fix should be should be the same,
though.
Yeah. Yeah. The the fix in in both
scenarios is the same.
Can also Brain
file. I have to look at the mutating
webhooks.
You can use API resources to get a
list of the resources on the cluster.
I'll do the same source.
The
oh, what's that? KeyCastle
completion
bash, was that? That's what it was.
It might be a caret instead of the
dollar.
Yeah.
Less than symbol instead of dollar.
Oh, okay. Yeah. Oh, yeah. No. Caret.
You still got the
Right?
No space. There's not space at all. Yeah.
No space.
Okay. It's fine.
Kiev gets
it's probably a validating. Right? So validating
web book.
Oh, you're gonna go for a fire hammer
approach? Yeah. Delete it.
Yeah. I mean, why not?
What's the worst that can happen? Right? Go
to the mall. Yeah. Give it a go.
Okay. And I didn't get recreated by some
magic.
I'm surprised that worked, actually.
If it was I'll I'll take that better
luck then.
That's absolutely fine.
What was the other one? And it was
in webtighting webhook.
Yeah.
If I can type
mutation,
which there isn't any
they're not names based on that. Okay.
So now what have we got?
Status don't hold. We've now got a Postgres
that's just come to life.
What was my desktop?
So what's the honk? Because I'm guessing
it's a status we're getting honked. So
is there something in writing an HCD?
The status is
hunk.
We we haven't bothered with it. We haven't
bothered with it. Okay. Good. I'm much too
scared to go in there. API server.
Perhaps there's some modify the code in the
API server to return hunk.
It's back fail restarting
thing.
You can have a look at the processes
to to see if there's anything suggestive.
But it is but it is actually right?
So Yeah. That's true.
Alright. Let's just optimistically change the thing and
then get rid of the readiness probe just
to
make it so that it's ready.
Once you do this, then you wanna should
we have a look at the API server
config?
Yeah. Sure. I'm just gonna I get I'm
just gonna push in that the thing does
work. So I'm gonna get rid of the
Yeah. Readiness and the liveliness
because I'll assume that we've done an excellent
job and that that that's that's container's absolutely
fine, and it never needs to be checked.
Okay. So we've got another one now.
But what's responsible for writing the status on
a pod?
Might
have a bit better luck if you
watch what's happening to the status.
Updating
endpoint sizes.
Node.
Not. What's that?
Yeah. James set this one up, and it
doesn't show up in
events either, which is quite brutal.
What he's looking for in the process list?
Anything?
Are there any
Anything that looks keywords you can think of
that might be worth grabbing for?
Grab for a hunk.
Yeah. Lower lowercase might work.
Hold on. It's very good.
Okay. Very good. That's that's almost a a
hacker's reference. Right?
What
have you done?
And where is that? Oh, it's in a
container somewhere, presumably.
What container is that gonna be in? Presumably
the API server. Right? Yeah. Probably.
Or the cubelet,
maybe. The cubelet on the nodes might be
sending that back.
You can also see the the parent of
the of
the process.
How did you do that? I'm trying to
It's a
Try e f.
E f. And then it's the
what was the thing?
It's
that one.
Oh, there's a funny namespace somewhere.
So that one, and there was a
container's in an angry geese.
Container
d, but it's not running actually in there.
So what are you thinking just now?
I'll try to get rid of that JS
policy thing that's not helping us anyway. But
the
there's a
container namespace of angry geese,
which seems suspect. I did that p s
dash e f, but that's giving me, like,
a load of things, not just the tree.
I think I did p s dash e
f, didn't I?
Yeah.
I think you're doing it with a what
was the number?
That was the number of the process that
we cared about. Right? That opts
honk the planet.
So I wanted to see the parent of
that process.
It was this one. Right?
Can you just do PSEF on its own?
You should get a tree. I could be
mistaken.
Oh, you need a
So I think you've got two avenues right
now.
You're suspecting that this the file does not
exist on the host. You're you're pretty much
looking for a container that's running it. So
I mean, you can run a QControl get
pods all and look for random container accounts
in a pod, or you're gonna have to
use cry control to list containers that are
running outside of Kubernetes.
But if you're happy that that looks normal,
then you're gonna wanna start looking for containers
that are not in the Kubernetes namespace.
Yeah. Thanks, Noah. It was p s f
a u x for the tree.
Yeah. F a u x is really good.
So
it might not help me at all, but
I'm just gonna
delete all the pods and let everything come
back in case it wasn't set up as
something that was persistent.
That sounds like a scary thing to do.
Why not?
No. I I don't know if you delete
everything. Don't delete anything from cube system.
Why not? It's just a pod. It will
come back.
Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, no one's telling me not to,
that it'll be a really bad idea. What's
the what's what's the container runtime on this?
Container d. So you could just crack Should
we should we check what containers are running?
We can indeed. There's also Cryo control. I'm
guessing they're just running.
I'm guessing you you started that container using
the the runtime.
Yes. So let me add the flag for
you just because I do know it off
the
Yeah. I've never used a cryo control.
Oops. Sorry. Oops. Sorry. Sorry.
Run.
Right. Look at that.
Ah, okay. Cool.
Okay. So can we check what containers are
running?
You can also use CTR
and do a CTRPS
as well. So it depends whether you want
look at it from Kubernetes context or from
a container d context.
You could do.
It's l s.
Is it?
PC l s. So this container PC l
s. Okay.
Yeah. L
s. Right.
So But it's in a
in that angry geese namespace. Right? So Yes.
So you can add a dash n to
that. Yeah.
What was it? Angry
geese,
which we saw.
Yeah. You need to put the n before
Before
the c, I think. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. It's
a bit of a pain.
There we go. Cool.
Okay. That'll do it. So that's the thing
I wanna get rid of.
So
what was the that's l s. So what's
the
You can do a CRM.
CRM. Okay.
Start by that.
Then It's a spice.
C space r m and then the ID.
Okay.
You must have been the task first.
Dash dash f.
Or dash f. Sorry. Or dash dash force.
No?
Maybe you might have to We're
all showing our container d ignorance here.
You might have to stop the task first.
So if you do TLS,
t space l s. Okay.
So say again. Say t space l s.
C c t r
Yeah. T
for task.
Like that? Space space l s. Yeah. Yeah.
And then Okay.
Now we can remove it.
So you need to RM both the task
on the container.
Okay.
Okay. Fine.
And you might even need to
stop the task first sometimes. I have to
shut down the machine.
I was just trying to Why Nerd
CTL is much nicer if you have it,
but it's
Yeah. Nerd CTL is good.
Alright. So So what was Stop the task.
Right. See, task
syntax for that is, like, kill that task.
And then
r m that task.
I think the killer should hopefully have done
that. You'll now need to do a container
l s to see if the container still
exists, and if so, you'll need to remove
that too.
Yeah.
But my task is still running even though
I've killed it.
Yeah. So now you should be able to
remove the container. Oh, wait. It is still
running. I mean, the task is still running.
You sometimes have to do kill dash s
sig kill.
Then yeah.
Alright. Okay. Stop.
It is.
It's back running again. Fucker.
Yeah. Can you I would try a t
r m dash
f. Must be a force flag on that
task or task delete.
Well, we saw it stop momentarily. So can
I just, like, string the commands along each
other? Is there some delay between them?
There isn't an extra thing that we made
you do here, by the way. You should
just be able to
kill RM and then RM the container.
It's a work Always.
Restarting
it. You've done some other accidental magic.
We'll check the parameters on t r m.
There must be a a way to force
remove this thing.
Yeah.
Fine.
Would you like me to type for a
moment? Because
I'm really curious.
Yeah.
I was gonna do that or just I
was gonna exec into it and just stop
it doing whatever it's doing. I just want
to do an RN dash f and that's
gone now.
What was doing? I'm
sure that's what I did at some point.
You need to check for the container.
So it's c l s, and then I
want to
see our
Stop on that one, I think.
Because who needs consistent
contacts?
No? Yeah. And You can't do CRM, I
think.
Oh, yeah. We were doing CRM earlier.
I did r m. That's how I'm thinking
because it wasn't stopped. Is there any parameters
to r m?
You might need to do a dash dash
help. Yeah. It
doesn't look like that.
No, let's just keep snapshots there. Yeah. You're
gonna have to do a
Why is the container still there?
Is the task still there? Let's do a
TLS
because I'm curious if it's magically come back.
Yes. But
Right. Okay. If I just exec onto the
running thing, and then I can do some
other magic and just stop it doing the
thing that it's doing,
maybe.
You want to
use Nerd CTL. It's it's way more comfortable
to use. It's more more Docker style.
Also not available on the machine right now,
though.
Okay. Unless we downloaded it and put it
somewhere sneaky
on the machine.
You think we're gonna trust your tools?
Trust them on the mind. Yeah. You you
type dot n c t l?
Let's just attach onto the thing and quickly
if I can see if can do that
quickly, and then
what was I gonna say? MS is task
exec,
like, onto that. Presumably, I'm gonna guess what
the syntax is.
You need a parameter called dash dash exec
dash pid.
I sorry. Exec ID
for reasons I don't understand.
And who says continue is not easy to
work with.
Alright. I'm gonna throw it. Why don't you
try a task pause? Like, we don't actually
need to get rid of it. We just
want to stop it doing its naughty things.
Right? Correct. Let's try a t pause.
No. That's a good shot.
Oh,
that board.
And then confirm with a
yeah.
I don't know. Still running.
That's that's not fair.
Is there is there a process that's starting
to or
That that failing, yeah, you can
see if you can identify a process that
you might be able to kill. Yeah. There's
a process that's probably running this. Let me
check.
Any other processes?
Grep for maybe angry or geese or hunk.
That's the one, isn't it?
Container edition one c.
Mainstream.
That doesn't help.
Yeah. The shim was always gonna be recreated.
Just
in the interest of time,
how did you just create this task? Because
I'm really surprised task RN didn't get rid
of it. You got a system deep process
running or a rogue script?
Node CTL with always restart.
Okay.
So if you type dot dot n CTL,
you'll get Node CTL.
And it might be a few fix the
problem. Problem. You should be able to kill
it from that
a bit more easily.
Yeah.
It looks like the always kind of thing
isn't an official
container d feature.
So I think it does some magic to
keep itself alive.
Sneaky sneaky. Good to know.
I don't think we even expected it to
stay alive this long. Stay
around for a bit.
Alright. Is it gone?
Is it actually gone?
Chris is doing everything. Stop. Kill our end.
Just to make sure.
Great. Bye. Bye.
Okay. Not a terminate. Oh, you've been terminated
for a while, aren't you? So I'm assuming
your anger, Geese, was constantly updating the status
of those
pods.
Mhmm.
So
run a world through loop.
You have
that's not good considering you deleted that namespace.
JS policy.
Yeah.
You're gonna have to check for those still
coming. Like, mission controllers.
Yeah.
The original intention with the policy engine
was to have the admission controller get in
the way,
but also protect itself from removal.
But but that didn't quite work.
Alright. Ten minutes that you'd have to remove
the admission Yep. At all.
I think delete them both
webhooks.
Maybe
the dash dash all didn't actually work in
the back end.
It did appear to work.
Yeah.
Alright. I'll just do your busy bots again.
And just make sure that JS policy is
gone because it it might be recreating this.
Oh, yeah. Definitely. It will will be.
But that that doesn't matter.
Alright.
So now I've got a
thing that looks like it's gonna start.
Yeah. I think the creation is because your
you know, tag change.
Yes. The clustered is up.
Postgres, is it coming up?
Yeah.
That's good. No. Let's check it. I think
it's checked. It was up and running, both
of them, and just to get bugs. K.
Alright. Yeah. Cool.
I mean, I could optimistically
ask you to check it, but I'm
That's still version one. Right?
That do you wanna No. We changed it.
I think, don't we? We changed it already?
Yeah.
Well, let's check. Let's
check. Let's check. Yeah. Go on then. Go
for it. It's definitely not that.
That's gonna be something else.
Oh, failed to connect the database.
Authentication
failed. Okay.
But it that's it's got that far. So
the thing works, so I just now can't
connect to the database. Well, the database credentials
are all hard coded and configured in the
postgres stateful set.
Okay. But it was an old failure. That's
what you said. Right? Was an old failure.
Yeah. Connectivity looked good.
So just the password then?
K. You've got all
edits
a stateful set.
Yep. The password has been changed.
Ah, okay.
Where is the password?
I believe it's postgres
one two three,
but I will confirm for you now.
I really should know this. Is there anywhere
that I would have been able to find
it?
It's in that
text. On the workload. Yeah.
So the password should be
Postgres PostgresQL
one two three. Yep.
Okay. So I just had an extra few
characters thrown on the end. Oh, your machine
controllers are back. Back.
Fine. Machine controller.
I'm
not gonna care about trying to fix them
and change the things that kicks. Obviously, it
lets me get away with that quickly before
it respawns.
You're gonna have to delete GS policy pod
add deployment, sorry,
and the GS policy namespace. Oh, yeah. Yeah.
If I could delete that namespace, didn't I?
Yeah. But there's probably a finalizer on the
GS policy part.
I just delete the deployment and hope for
the best rather than namespace.
No. I'm gonna bother looking at what it
is.
Alright. And then
one more thing. Three, two, one.
Nice.
Okay. Give me a sec.
Not healthy yet.
Alright. There we go. Let's try refresh.
Yeah. Yeah. You got the dash. Oh, it's
right.
Nice work.
Work.
Good work.
Five minutes to spare. Loads of time.
Well done.
Yeah. Nice clusters there. Well done, everyone.
Yeah. Good job, guys.
Good job. Yeah. Was really good.
So that's a really I I think the
takeaway there for me, I had no idea
that nets nerds control offered that always restart.
Like, that's that's not behavior I expected to
see from continuity there. So, like, does NerdControl
have a long running process that was instigating
that? I'm not sure.
So we were
were Go on, Jack. Sorry.
I was gonna say, yeah, when you when
you add the dash dash always,
I'm not sure how exactly it works. But
we noticed, like, it injects itself in to
the container to like capture logs and stuff.
So
it must do
do some injection where it like adds itself
in so it can
re add containers or
something.
Yeah. A sneaky
one.
Then Magic. Basically. Magic. That's what I was
describing.
And I also love that the you never
really got the GS policy thing doing exactly
what you wanted, but it was still causing
absolute havoc through the entire thing as well.
Yeah. I'm not sure if it can cause
kinda more hassle that way or not.
But yeah.
Alright. Well,
yeah.
Those those are great. Well done, both teams.
Good job breaking. Good job fixing. I think
we've seen a nice mixture of different stuff
there, which is always fun to see. So
thank you for for taking time out of
your week. You know, it's it's not easy
to break these clusters even if you leave
it to the last minute, Solo. Just saying.
Just saying. Always. Always. Best by the time
that's high aspirations of things we do.
But
it was a pleasure. It was good watching
you's work. We learned a lot today, so
thank you for taking time out of your
day to join us. Thank you to everyone
that watched, and thank you to Teleport for
sponsoring. Remember to check out Teleport at Rawkodelive/Teleport.
Alright. Any last words from anyone before I
let you get back to your evening?
No. Thank you very much for having us.
Long time watcher,
first time
streamer, I guess.
You've got you've got Lewis hovering above this.
So
thank you all. Thanks for having us. Alright.
Thanks, everyone. Have a great day. I'll see
you all soon. Adios. See you. Bye.